and finally new rule trumped arrangement
syndrome isn't a real thing so don't
make it one Republicans accused
Democrats these days of hating Trump
irrationally like everything he does is
awful except everything he does is awful
so on the rare occasion when he says
something not stupid don't act like you
have trumped arrangement syndrome it
happened last weekend when Trump weighed
in on the second max Adair crash by
tweeting airplanes are becoming far too
complex to fly I see it all the time in
many products always seeking to go one
unnecessary step further when often old
and simpler is far better and who knows
better about old it's simpler
but TV pundits were all over that tweet
saying it proved that Trump wanted to go
back in time to our racist past okay he
does want that but this wasn't about
that sometimes a cigar is just a cigar
and he's right we do over-engineer [ __ ]
all the time and designing a plane where
the autopilot software sometimes steers
it into the dirt is just the most tragic
example the second most tragic example
is my old babe my old bake the packs I
liked it a lot I mean I would have if I
was a pot smoker no packs and I shared a
lot of good times but then it fell
victim to the upgrade bug the new model
doesn't have a mouthpiece which is an
odd thing to get rid of for something
you stick in your mouth
you can't suck it and that sucks it was
perfectly fine the way it was and now
it's so hard to use this thing I'm so
close to watching Morning Joe not stoned
this is what I call reverse improvement
making it upgrade that nobody wants
needs or likes they do it with vape pens
to press five times to turn off press
three times listen I'm here on earth to
have a good time not to read instruction
manuals the last thing you want to do
when you're high is figure [ __ ] out
never get stoned before assembling IKEA
furniture you you spend the whole time
thinking who is Alan and why is this
wrench named after
cars these days have more useless
features than Jared Kushner why was
replacing the car door handle with a
button and improvement it's not because
it's not better if everything in the car
is run by a computer because the [ __ ] is
always glitchy once while I was driving
a voice-activated rental car I said car
turn on headlights the car said would
you like to open the trunk I said open
the trunk [ __ ] no opening trunk no
closed trunk turn on lights I don't know
what stupid or a feature where you can
verbally open your trunk at 60 miles an
hour we're getting into an argument with
a car last weekend I was in Dallas the
faucet in the sink in my dressing room
looked like this now I need it to hot
water to shave and cold water to wash my
face and I never found out how to make
that happen
the black thing in the middle makes the
water go on but hot and cold I quote
what the [ __ ] you sink because when I
say I want it hot it says I'm sorry Dave
I'm afraid I can't do that
there's even a smart toilet now although
let's be honest if it was really that
smart would it be a toilet now they are
working on a toilet that analyzes your
pee as it hits the side of the bowl and
gives a readout of all your vital
functions that's fantastic
I'm always for real progress but that's
not this this toilet says it's a quote
fully immersive experience because who
doesn't want to be immersed in a toilet
I'm not kidding it has Bluetooth Alexa
built-in speakers and mood lighting so
you can pretend you're taking a dump in
the middle of Studio 54 in 2017 Apple
unveiled facial recognition technology
for opening your phone because
remembering four digits what is it's an
IQ test so this is what happened
unlocking it is as easy as looking at it
and swiping up and you know let's try
that again
oh ho let's uh go to back up here Apple
itself can't get the [ __ ] to work at
their own show
what shot do we have there's always a
glitch like last week when Nike get this
right into a problem with their new
self-lacing sneakers
yes self-lacing for people who literally
can't tie their shoes and chew gum at
the same time so instead of tying your
shoes on your own you know like a loser
you simply put on your shoes pull out
your phone find Wi-Fi open the app enter
your password find the button that says
tie shoes close the app return the phone
to your pocket and catch up to your
friends who left 15 minutes ago
you